[Music]
the uh oscars are this weekend oh i can
tell everyone here has oscar fever
again no one has oscar fever
i love when they talk about that whole
town's got oscar fever yeah
you're going to need some oscar panic
soon for that oscar yeah
get me my oscar thermometer for the off
the fever yeah
i should stop i know right
i'm just tired of hearing people say
that yeah
but anyway here's uh one big story
warhorse is one of the nine films
nominated for best picture
and warhorse is also nominated for best
original music score yeah
now i i'm okay with warhorse being
nominated for best picture but music
score that surprised me because
i watched the film i found the music
kind of distracting decide for yourself
take a look at this scene
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man i love that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
dumbest thing we've ever done
and that's really saying something yeah
that's in the really dumb thing we've
done hall of fame and that is going to
that song is going to stick in our
brains for a long time yeah i'll be
drinking my wife
yeah
my wife is going to be in the middle of
the night i'm going to be like a clam
[Laughter]
did it happen again